welcome to the Michaela Peterson podcast
this is episode 11 today's episode I
spoke to Lauren southern Lauren southern
is a best-selling author an
internationally famous journalist and
recently the creator of borderless the
most comprehensive documentary to date
detailing the European border crisis
Lauren recently stepped out of the
public eye to focus on her family
including her newborn first child this
is her first podcast back in over a year
and I was really excited to talk with
her we met up in person back in 2016 to
have a few drinks and talk about well we
mainly talked about diet to be honest it
was good to see her again she looks
exactly the same even though she's now
married with a child we spoke at length
about our experiences moms particularly
what being a young mom is like Lauren
and I both had our kids at 25 which is
young for North American Sanders we
spoke about birth control the current
state of the world and what Lauren is
going to be up to in the future I hope
you enjoyed this episode
[Music]
lorne southern welcome to my podcast
thanks for having me it's been a while
since I've done anything yeah when was
the last time the internet saw you like
more or less in video form well two
weeks ago but before that over a year
it's been over a year since I've done
any interviews and you can tell yeah
because well you can't tell actually
only I can tell because I put on perfume
for this interview and I sat down well I
get it like it's kind of exciting
after you have a baby that's what you've
been doing right that's where you
disappeared off to yes I had a baby I
found out I was pregnant right before
the release of my documentary and yeah I
didn't really tell anyone I kind of
wanted it to just be a thing for me so
much of what we do in our day to day
life we feel the need to share with the
Internet it has to be a photo and
everything it's just like recording 24/7
and I could just kind of wanted my baby
my family to just be for me for at least
a small while a small portion of myself
guys that was really nice yeah well how
like when did you start getting more
known out there on the interweb on the
interwebs oh man I would have been 19
years old just crazy and looking back I
don't even think there has to be some
sort of restriction on the age you can
be to access the internet because the
amount of things you can do but yeah 19
I had this viral video
criticizing feminism and then
questioning people at [ __ ] walks and
they all just got in the millions of
views it was absurd like I looking back
I can't believe if I had been born even
five or ten years earlier before YouTube
have been made like my life would be
very very different yeah so how did you
manage I mean we'll get into a whole
bunch of more interesting things but one
thing I'm kind of focused on recently is
stress management because of what my
dad's been through in the last five
years and I think maybe being the
it's hard to say being thrown into like
relative Fame I think it's different
depending on what age you're thrown into
it at but how did you like balance or
manage that because you were well-known
and for something that was controversial
so it's not like you were it's not like
you were seen in a positive light from a
lot of people so how did you manage
staying sane through that it was very
much baptism by fire I kind of got this
wave of hate all at once and it was
super overwhelming I just remember being
so upset about it
lots of people were lying about me
online I just said slanderous articles
being uploaded everywhere I people from
my high school signing petitions to get
me kicked out of political parties and
university and that's that hits
differently like when it's random people
on the Internet you can kind of it still
hurt yeah yeah no can kind of shrug your
shoulders but when it's people you know
and you see the names of people you went
to high school with and friends signing
petitions that you cancelled it was a
lot but trial by fire you know that
first year on the internet you learn the
ways and you just if you want to keep
doing it you got to get a thick skin and
I actually looking back I don't
necessarily think that was a great thing
for my mental health or anyone's mental
health just get this attitude that
nothing you read online matters like not
care about anyone's opinions and just be
able to do quickly it you can get a bit
sociopathic I think spending too much
time online especially as a public
figure because you just you know ever
everything anyone says to you is water
off your shoulders you know you just
don't care and a piano but you have it
it's a survival mechanism for sure just
having that switch of don't care don't
care what any of you say don't care if
the entire crowd is screaming at me just
being able to shut off that switch shame
it's a it's a raise II I don't know if
you'd call it a talent but ability that
I just think people in this modern age
are happened
learn to develop because of this very
very toxic online environment oh yeah
that that's interesting and maybe I
don't know if being 19 what being 19 is
young but have you ever done I feel like
when we met up a couple of years earned
a number of years ago did you do dads
personality test
did IRA send that to you I did do it I
can't remember my exact result to
remember them being crazy though like
some things you've got to be yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's not surprising I'm sure
you're fairly low in neuroticism to be
able to handle that much stress or
adaptable anyway mm-hmm I do think we'll
get into this I'm sure pipes stepping
away from the internet and motherhood
has definitely changed my feelings and
my approach to life and the Internet in
general though if I go back to looking
at my 19 year old self a lot of the
things I could do then like standing and
holding signs of the SlutWalk and just
like saying some things that were super
inflammatory to a crowd I'd look at
myself and I feel I just wouldn't do
that now
I just wouldn't I think there are more
[Music]
respectable and kinder ways to get a
point across anything perhaps thinking
that now and realizing that and wanting
to have more of a nuanced and genuine
less inflammatory discussion with people
wouldn't have gotten me the same amount
of attention yeah as me being younger
and just full of this kind of just
zealot tree of like I'm so excited to
just say this opinion no matter who it
pisses off so if I hide my personality
now when I was 19 and trying to get big
on YouTube what and it happened I don't
think people people really like that
just it's like louder more flashy or
angry or more emotional than a
reasonable conversation yeah fair enough
okay so I want to get into you like
you've done a lot of political things in
your past and I kind of wanted to talk
about what your experience as a mom has
been because you struck me and tell me
if I'm wrong but when we when we met you
didn't strike me as someone who you
think you told me you you wanted to find
a husband have a family but you didn't
strike me as somebody who was pritchard
who was
maternal right compared to some women
that you meet that it's like that person
who's gonna be a stay-at-home mom and
she's gonna love doing that and she's
gonna have tea with a whole bunch of
two-year-olds and that's gonna be what
fulfills her as a person which is
totally fine but you didn't strike me as
that kind of person so what has being a
mom been like for you know however long
you've been a mom for you know it's it
is something that has come out in me a
lot more since giving birth like I think
maybe hormones have to do with that I
don't know just like the love for my
child wanting to be around him all the
time but I totally get that I heard that
all the time you're never gonna have
kids I also questioned it myself I'm
like yeah it's something I want but I
also really like working I also really
like mm-hm
you know traveling the world doing all
this stuff but when you meet the right
person and kids are something that you
want how is it changed to be more
maternal I mean it's I haven't thought
about this is fine because I haven't
really thought about it that deeply
because it did kind of just come
naturally to me
like as soon as I found out I was
pregnant I was like I need to step back
from the Internet I want to focus on my
child I want to focus on my family I
want to make sure that I have low stress
levels want to give birth I want to make
sure I can focus my attention on him you
know breastfeeding staying up all night
going to Mum classes like it wasn't even
like a checklist of duties it came so
naturally and was something I was so
excited to do and still everyday I'm so
excited to do that it's it wasn't
something that I I thought about at all
or haven't even thought about because it
came so naturally I don't think that
means that I've necessarily lost that
other side of me though that has this
adventurous want to go getter
personality and this is something that
I've really learned is there's this
picture out there of women and mums and
that's all they are and that's all they
can do and regrettably I think I kind of
he pushed this trope a little bit as
well sometimes am I talking about
traditional women and traditional
families and older videos and speeches
I've done and I've even see people
comment on it when I post it on
Instagram why are you on Instagram why
are you back to doing documentaries you
should just be a mom
well no mums are multi-dimensional human
beings men aren't just wallets get back
to the cubicle you know we are
multi-dimensional human beings and also
people who make comments like that
clearly don't have kids cuz what do you
expect me to do for three hours and my
son is napping am I supposed to just
stare at him all day no I wanted to be
having productive I want to use my
creative energy and that's gonna make me
a better mother as well is not just
being this person who's me and stays at
home all day and has no opinions on
anything or hasn't created anything no I
moms are multi-dimensional people yeah
yeah it's funny
when I was pregnant I had like I did a
total 182 and was like everything in my
life I just want to be not stressed that
was a big goal I want to be not stressed
because it's been shown like if you're
not stressed even the birth process goes
a lot it goes a lot it's a lot safer to
have a baby if you're not completely
full of cortisol while you're having a
baby
and so my priorities changed a lot too
because I'm fairly work oriented and it
lasted almost the well it was about like
six months after I had scarlet then I
started looking more into work and then
after I stopped breastfeeding it was
like I changed completely back into who
I was prior to the pregnancy it was I'm
like my hormones were insane it was
insane how my brain changed throughout
the period it was nuts
my hormones are still out of whack it's
so funny that you mentioned that I've
been working on my diet the last little
bit to try and fix my hormones because I
went into a doctor recently to go and
get everything back to normal and of
course the first thing they say is
basically birth control birth control
will regulate your cycle it'll regulator
yeah you know yeah I don't like birth
control I don't like putting things like
that in my ball
I've got it in a packet well I've been
doing lots of research I haven't taken
it yeah I've been doing lots of plus not
good for breastfeeding so I'm gonna try
something called seed cycling have you
ever heard of it I haven't
what does seed cycling I literally just
found it on a random website I went out
and bought all the seeds that I'm
supposed to get apparently things like
flax seed sunflower seed pumpkin seed
all these different things have lots of
different hormones in them estrogen and
if you take them at certain times of the
month you can regulate your hormones
naturally just using seeds gonna try it
I have no idea if it's gonna work but
I'd rather do something like that
naturally that sounds way safer yeah cut
sugar which has been so helpful was it
hard it takes me about two weeks every
time I do it and then after two weeks
it's not hard it's like my body was
forgotten about it
okay good that's good yeah I definitely
I had a pretty nasty experience with
birth control and I think a lot of
people a lot of women get depressed when
they're on it and they don't even know
right they're like why am i moody and
miserable like it could be the pill that
you've been on since we were you know 14
that nobody's telling I'm not a birth
control fan it made me more crazy than I
already am and one of my best friends
was super stable she went nuts on it
anecdotes but still I tried it for a
short while and I just remember gaining
weight that was the thing it definitely
changes probably a bit too much in your
body because everyone gets these like
crazy reactions to it some people good
like they get rid of all their acne but
mmhmm yeah definitely prefer the natural
well like you know if the seed cycling
works could be focus but okay you put up
a post the other day and it showed a
fairly flattering picture of you and you
said something along the lines of the
you know post pregnancy body or that
babies ruin your body is a myth can you
delve into that a little bit yeah so
I was always terrified of having a kid I
remember when I was in high school I
know it's so vain but ladies don't
pretend you're not paying sometimes I
was like it's gonna destroy my body I
don't have a good kid
I don't want to have like this tummy
that's just all over the place and like
I just don't want my body to be
completely ruined by a child and of
course you got a bit older and you're
like okay there's sacrifices you have to
Bank for things that you want so I was
like great I'll just deal with it
I'll deal with all the stretch marks
I'll deal with the weight gain I'll deal
with all of the problems that come with
giving birth and then I gave birth and
my body is literally completely back to
normal like the exact same I was sitting
there and every single person told me
they're like your vagina is gonna tear
your tummy is gonna be horrible all of
this stuff is gonna happen nothing like
it was no problems afterwards I was
shocked and now I know that is my story
and other women have different stories
other women do have stretch marks they
do care they do have issues giving birth
but the more I thought about it and even
now just thinking about it to call
something ruined or destroyed I find it
difficult to apply that word to a
natural process like your women are
supposed to give birth we have been
doing this since the dawn of time and if
it causes stretch marks if it causes
some weight gain if it causes other
issues that's not destroying your body
that is literally going through a
natural process we don't call like how
dare you destroy your body when you age
and you get wrinkles like this is a
natural process and so I just I feel
like the idea of the ruined mom bod as
in any woman who has a child her body is
gonna be completely destroyed and
different I think that's a myth and even
if a woman's body is different after
birth to call it destroyed or ruined I
don't think I think that's like it's
more like battle scars like it's a guy
coming back from war
he's just fought he's lost an arm in a
blast
he comes home and people are like oh you
ruined your body like what no that is a
battle scar that is a badge of honor
like you fought for your country staying
with women you created a human being
that is a battle scar like be proud of
those things of course it's not fun it's
not easy all the time I have tons of
female friends of mine that had horrific
crazy birth stories that every single
one of them was like it is worth it
would do it again for my kid 100,000%
mm-hmm yeah I know I was shocked too I
think it has something to do with with
age like how old are you now I just
turned 25 definitely I would agree with
that the no difference age is absolutely
a factor I was reading studies about it
and there isn't much documented
documented history of tearing and women
from giving birth prior to recently like
the last 50 to a hundred years because
women used to have birth so young so
these things just weren't as common yeah
it's not just it's not just age it's not
just age either the rate of like I don't
know how you had your birth but most
people have epidurals and if you're
older and you have an epidural because
you can't actually feel anything that's
going on the rate of Tears is way higher
because you have no sensation and you
know what blew my mind to doing research
into this is the rates of women dying in
childbirth in the u.s. right now or
actually going up not going down and the
reason is because of also just the
medical practices and the way the system
works trying to make money and trying
not to waste time they are constantly
suggesting women get c-sections when
they do not need them so the doctor says
okay we can make 30 grand or whatever
off a c-section yep give her that plus
it's less time it's
what less than an hour over having this
woman in here for 13 hours like yeah
we're gonna do a c-section because we
make money off it and we get them outta
here a quick turnover but that is super
unhealthy if you don't need it
super likely ant rates of infection
bleeding all of these things so there
are more women dying today from
childbirth
then previously it's going up and that
is insane to me yeah I had the same
experience I researched and you probably
did the same thing I researched as much
as I possibly could before I had scarlet
I actually had a home birth because so
it was intense it was so awesome though
but yeah I was in a tub it was crazy
my husband was like his eyes were like
saucers but anyway I did a lot of
research into kind of what happens what
the statistics are in a hospital versus
at home and more so for your second or
third kid because that's usually when
people have them at home they don't do
the first one they're usually but the
rates of you know clamps obviously
c-section all those things are much much
lower at home and even being transferred
to a hospital you know if you're near a
hospital it's fairly safe but yeah
thirty percent of women have c-sections
in North America and it's not like 30%
of women need c-sections otherwise
people who are in rural towns or debris
things at a time yeah yeah it's insane
so it's not a conspiracy theory it's
just it's ridiculous um yeah I could
like I could go off on a rant about that
date because that's unneeded abdominal
surgery it's actually totally screwed up
right I mean it's different if you need
one but if you don't need one it's a
pretty intense thing to do to somebody
to speed up their birth I had like a
crazy birth plan that I've written now
you know like the so they've got like
the level they've basically got a menu
of drugs that you can take when you're
giving birth like I'll take a bit of
that I'll take the laughing gas the car
all good
whatever it is fentanyl
and then they've got like the different
procedures that can happen and I made
sure I had on my form that I gave to my
husband
no c-section if they say a c-section is
necessary like absolutely yeah under
percent necessary get a second opinion
from a second doctor because sometimes
I'll literally say that that would be
the first thing they say this is
necessary we're doing it right now so
get a second opinion I did end up
getting an epidural I got the laughing
gas
no Seco this is kind of nice and then it
started really hurting then I got the
epidural I don't know like I feel like
my birth it was so quick it was eight
hours from start to finish
oh yeah that's good I was literally like
texting my mom in the sending me was
like when you're expecting I was the
girl that sneezed and had twins that's
great though I I think that well that
must have something to do with age I had
scarlet when I was how old was I was I
25 or 26 25 I don't know how old I was I
think I was 25 and I didn't end up
having an epidural and I literally
hallucinate 'add when the just like
those pattern like diamond shapes you
get right before the intense
contractions started because it was you
get an increase in oxytocin and it was
just like oh this is awesome and it was
just naturally gave you that yeah the
oxytocin because you get a huge kick of
oxytocin and then it's like you're on
Aaron full-on labor and it was like
shrew me so it was awesome but it like
hurt it was not easy
and then sounds like it was kind of like
this is cool and it was like oh my god
that was the strangest experience of my
entire life you know what so the nurse
came up to me and I was just like not so
I actually put no epidural on my birth
plan
and I remember asking for the epidural
on my husband it's like but you don't
want the epidural on me like there's no
trophy for not getting the epidural
there's no prize at the end for not
doing it like some women want to do the
full natural thing but maybe now that
you're saying these statistics around
that I'd have to do more research but
well I just know mine went really well
yeah yeah that's good well I think
that's also combined with age and it
depends if you also have like there's so
many people in North America that are
already unhealthy like slippery
gestational diabetes like that's really
high in women in the states too so that
complicates things further if you're
already healthy then the risks are a lot
lower but it was pretty wild without it
just because of the hormones I mean an
epidural really shouldn't block those
but I did hallucinate it was wild did
you make you sign a form before you get
the epidural be like I'm on laughing gas
I'm like screaming and they bring me a
form and they're like and by the way
section 3 4 yeah then you might be
paralyzed if we put it in like just give
me the form like I don't care legally
allowed to be signing a pole right now
but whatever yeah right oh well anyway
I'm glad it went well that's good it's
good he had a good experience ok so I
asked my Instagram followers questions
if they had questions for you and I was
like we're gonna talk mom things and the
main response was isn't she a dad what's
the story what's the story behind that
what are you yeah in Ontario I'm legally
a man this is actually about the time
that your dad was getting in lots of
trouble for his whole the pronoun stuff
at University of Toronto and it was
announced that you could change your
gender on your ID in Canada if you I
looked up the rules for it if you
brought a medical form saying that you
were a different gender so within and I
am not even joking within 8
two hour time span I was able to go to a
doctor get a doctor's note diagnosing me
as a male and then go into Service
Canada and change my province ID to male
and I still have that ID today in
Ontario my province idea is still male
and yeah did that within two hours and
you know what to be honest looking at
that to say you could do that in two
hours I think that is a point for both
people for people who look at it either
way if you are someone who is
transgender isn't that kind of taking
the piss out of your experience that I
can just go and do that in two hours
without any of the like years of effort
hormones gender dysphoria anything like
I could just go in and a doctor is too
afraid to actually do a proper check
over and look over of me because they
don't want to be fired from their job
and then on the other side people who
would say you know you shouldn't be able
to just change your gender in two hours
that's insane yeah it was a bizarre
thing but technically if I take my
family to Ontario I am in a gay
relationship and I am a dad I suppose
that's so weird
what year was that that was 20 was that
2016 that would have been faces India
2016 yeah well things are do you think
things are weirder now than they were
then they're kind of a darker weird like
this timeline is taking a really dark
turn I was a good year to take away but
I I look at everything going on right
now and people are just angry and
vitriolic and I think with you did a
video on it talking about how unhealthy
the lockdown is for people's mental
health I mean just on all levels
mental health out the window like
counsellors are overloaded with work
abuse in homes is through the roof
suicides rates going up and I this is
something that I've realized over the
last year spending a lot of time in
person with Pete
I actually maybe I'll tell a story about
it later but I went to like a hardcore
feminist womb night for women let's talk
about their birth experiences and it was
a really interesting experience for me
it's something that I've come to realize
is politics in a lot of cases is people
dealing with personal trauma at a
distance like you look at people that
are into hardcore feminism or even
hardcore men's rights usually they've
had some personal traumatic experience
that they can't really process and so
they get involved in these strongly
opinionated political communities to
deal with their trauma at a distance and
I am seeing that happen in so many ways
with what is happening right now in the
states even on racial levels with the
black lives matter stuff white lives
matter stuff everyone has got a lot of
trauma mental health issues and they are
taking it out in a political form and I
gotta say I know it firsthand politics
is the worst form of therapy people the
worst form of therapy it's not the least
stressful that's for sure yeah Wow yeah
I think I think a lot of what we're
seeing today right now in the media of
cancelled canceling everyone people's
just anger and betrayal it's it's really
coming from this this mental health
crisis we're having around kovat yeah
yeah I completely agree I mean it was
yeah it was building right it's been
building since 2016 a lot of the
politically correct stuff that's
stressful for people but I mean the
protests and everything that's going on
is no wonder people are angry right now
because they've been trapped at home and
terrified like even I'm pretty like I'm
fairly stable and I researched fairly
thoroughly but going to a grocery store
and having it empty from food like are
empty of food that is stressful so
everyone's stressed is no wonder people
are like or they're like hey all my
friends are going to riot haven't seen
them in like four months like what a
better thing can't find a better thing
to do like it's people are just
ridiculously
stupid sometimes not looking at the
actual causes of things yeah yeah it's
um you know and a lot of the things that
we are getting just incensed and angry
about because we're stuck at home and
we're also getting people are getting
like coded benefits they're getting
checks from the government they're
getting help yes there is people that
are terrified because of losing their
job as well which is the factor like you
know if you go to places in the third
world or developing countries and you
tell them the kind of things that were
riding over like statues versus what
they're riding over like we didn't get
to vote or we literally aren't getting
to eat being stuck at home and just on
your computer all day
we are literally inventing problems that
don't really exist we are inventing
things to be angry about and to keep our
minds busy it's like this is Vita Activa
but we've constantly got going because
you're so I genuinely think not to say
problems with police brutality or
anything are caused because of boredom
but there is a level of the hysteria the
cancelling going online the we have to
get rid of the statue of the fish that's
racist for some reason because it's like
everyone is just stuck creating problems
at home all day there's not like real
things to deal with you know no one
would be protesting over a statue in a
third-world country because they have to
eat they have to deal with like things
we are stuck at home here on our
computers we are just creating these
environments that's also the media the
news it's what we like to consume if
people are getting paid to create this
Asteria people are getting paid to post
videos of everyone punching each other
everyone just so angry I think about it
all the time like when I walk down the
street in my town no one is there's no
riots anywhere no one is screaming at
each other because their different races
are wearing masks or not wearing masks
like I just I genuinely don't see that
stuff anywhere but if you're just
sitting online and you're just at home
that's what you're seeing every single
day 24/7 constantly because that's what
people
watch it's what goes viral you're not
gonna see the video of a bunch of
college students that disagree with each
other having a wonderful conversation
and then going home you're not gonna see
the woman who was politely asked to put
on a mask outside the store and just
that okay I'll go buy one or vice versa
you're not gonna see those things
because they're not interesting they're
not viral so part of it is a lot of
anger and then also a part of it is the
media are making making things seem
crazier than they are yeah a hundred
percent if there's any time to take a
social media break it was
well maybe now but a month to go for
sure it was like this is a disaster
everything everybody on here is infected
that was I've never seen anything like
it when the black lives matters thing
started happening it was like everybody
I knew almost but it went up from you
know maybe 50% of the media that I read
and I obviously don't read only like
leftist media I have like I go
everywhere but it went from you know 50
percent to everybody even even places I
thought were kind of more to the right
started getting infected that was that
was scary so I'm gonna switch I'm gonna
switch away a little bit from political
stuff one of the questions that like a
bunch of women on my Instagram asked was
how do you find like a good guy nowadays
I find a good guy nowadays oh my gosh
you know what I used to hmm I used to
kind of have this view that like your
goal in life as a woman is find a man
settle down get married I think it's an
awesome thing I think it's a beautiful
thing to do it's not for everyone I
don't think you should rush it I don't
think you should that should be the only
focus on your life I think women should
focus on themselves and improving
themselves and making yourself a better
person and eventually if you work on
yourself you will be you will find the
people that you attract and come to you
are of a higher caliber
I think so often especially when I look
at gender forums criticizing each other
men are like where of all the good women
gone mm-hmm why literally see things
like this all women are [ __ ]
why won't they date me well maybe that's
why they're not dating you because you
call them all [ __ ] all day you know
and and women that are insensitive anger
that they can't find where of all the
good men gone well if you work on
yourself and you start putting yourself
in a higher-caliber
instead of just you know accepting the
best thing to just appear in front of
you I I think that's the best thing you
can do instead of just chasing people
work on yourself we're caught one thing
that I was doing before I met my husband
was I was actually spending the a year
before I met my husband I made a
decision that I wanted to work on my
empathy and my heart and I had been it
was something that I kind of lost not
not that I didn't have it before but I
suppressed it in the face of a lot of
the attention I was getting online we
spoke about this at the beginning
there's so much hate that you get online
everyone wants something from you
everyone's pulling you in certain
directions and then they're all just
trying to get emotional reactions for
you so you shut down your empathy you
shut down your feelings and you just do
the job and one thing I really wanted to
regain was having that real when I
talked to people I wanted to have human
discussions which is hard because when
you can't do that when you've got tons
of people wanting to talk to you
constantly you don't have the energy for
it so I really put a concerted effort
into when people called me I would sit
and I'd actually have a long
conversation with them and listen to
their problems listen to their heart try
to understand them and feel for them and
work on my empathy work on my love for
people and as I was slowly working on
that I felt like the people that I was
meeting clicked with me more that would
have been potential partners like my
husband that would have been people that
it wants to undress my life with you
know
that's very insightful working on
yourself first that's then I love that
and that's really like good for you
honestly
that that's tough like um from what I've
seen with people about people who if you
have a large following
from my experience then and my
experience is nothing compared to like
my dad's but from my experiences you get
paranoid and you're like everybody who
meets you who knows you who knows of you
what do they want right it's like who
are your real friends and who are your
real friends really so it's very that's
fairly brave to try and open yourself up
again after years of that from such a
young age to it's it's a hard thing you
have to have a bit of an ego death as
well you really do because when you
start to open yourself up to empathy and
[Music]
almost looking at yourself as a human
being instead of a public figure again
you're open to self criticism you're
open to like like feeling these feelings
of fear and hurt when people criticize
you online and hate you and tear you
down and like that's a wave of emotions
that no one wants to deal with and
that's why I think the further people
get into media and fame the more I
actually think it's like it developed
kind of sociopathy and I think that's
where you get to the level where people
start doing drugs and becoming
alcoholics and everything because the
masks that they put on has become too
difficult to bear and so they have to
start doing drugs to keep it up they
have to start literally it's just it
becomes too much this kind of dual
personality the person they are for the
camera and then the person that you
secretly know you are in the back of
your head it's like anyone who does
online work has a bit of imposter
syndrome like I know I'm not as
wonderful as some people think I am on
camera and I also know I'm not as
terrible as some people think I am so
the image that people see of me online
versus who I actually am in the back of
my head creates the serious imposter
syndrome and taking a step back
a year for media and working on seeing
myself as a human being and not a public
figure
it was a emotionally exhausting and
almost traumatic experience but I'm so
glad I've done it because having the
ability to love and have human
connection and understand other people
and see people that disagree with me on
the other side of the political spectrum
as humans and not just tools to get
views or clicks I that is worth so much
more than any amount of fame or money so
much more and it's so good for your
mental health Wow so what's your plan
for the future and trying to balance
your online presence and your family
yeah I got a lot of criticism for coming
back from people that are kind of like
oh you need to be tried life you know
I've never claimed to be tried life and
I think that's kind of a trope you know
a lot of the things that people say
online about child life like women
should be in the kitchen mopping like
that's just what people do on a normal
Tuesday when they actually have a real
life and aren't just on the internet but
I there are times that my son naps that
I would spend time working and I spend
time writing and planning and there I've
got family on both sides grandparents my
husband people that love to watch and
take care of my son and also I don't
plan on overextending my presence online
I'm not gonna be on Twitter other than
talking about the documentary that I've
made or any big updates because I don't
think it's good for my mental health I
think it's a bit of a cesspool of just
vitriol to be quite frank
maybe if they put a little timer before
people send tweets that's like you have
to think about this for 15 minutes
before you send it maybe I would go on
Twitter again but it's literally just
people like instantly my first worst
most angry emotional thought I'm gonna
put out there on the Internet and that's
just not as Sasa I don't have the time I
don't
the energy for it I want to give my
emotional energy to my family and the
people I love and the projects that I'm
working on in a genuine way yeah yeah
Wow
good that's but it's good and your it's
good that you've figured that out I mean
what so you're thrown into the spotlight
kind of at 19 and then you're 25 now so
you've got like a lot of life ahead I
mean I'm only 28 but like but that's a
good time to figure out yeah I know I
feel ancient like after this year I'm
feeling kind of ancient but uh yeah
that's that's really cool okay so
another question what what I guess
what type of actions have really been
beneficial that your husband has
performed as a dad that's helped you as
a mom I know that's a bit complicated
but like as a good dad or a good like
mate what should men be like in order to
help their significant other a healthy
relationship look like this is such an
I've been thinking about this a lot this
is such an interesting question I think
it's so often we talk about marriage and
babies and family as just this end goal
like you watch movies as a kid growing
up that's a girl and it's like the
princess meets the prince then they get
married and it's happily ever after for
men they slay the dragon and then they
get the princess and it's happily ever
after no one tells you what to do when
you've actually got the princess no one
tells you what to do you've actually got
the prince no it's it's not really
discussed even online and kind of
circles that are obsessed with
traditionalism and have it they just
talk about it as this end goal but no
one really talks about what to do when
you're there and it's a difficult thing
marriage and babies are there's you know
I post on my Instagram this beautiful
photo of my wedding and baby and
everything I love all of it and it's
amazing but everyone knows that is
married and has babies it's a
challenging thing every day it is a
challenge that you work on together and
you grow together and you learn each
other you learn about each other there's
no there's no end to the learning as a
human being and growing as a human being
you know like even just right now my
husband is taking care of the baby and
giving him a bottle and just little
things like that are incredible um
incredibly helpful so I can do this
interview right now but it's a learning
experience every single day I the advice
I would give wouldn't be applicable to
someone else's situation I don't think I
think you you each have to be open to
growing and improving
it's just working if you love your child
and if you both truly deeply love your
child you will figure out what to do
that's that's best for them I believe as
parents yeah yeah one of the things I
had a really hard time learning and I'm
still learning is my dad always talked
about honesty and how important honesty
was and truthfulness and so I but I
always kind of felt that since I was a
kid probably because it was hammered
into me in such a young age but one of
the things I've had trouble with is
being honest to myself about my emotions
so if I'm annoyed about something I
don't know you might not have the same
problem but I find if I'm annoyed about
something or uncomfortable in this
situation I'll just like block it out
and continue going instead of actually
addressing the problem is that not
something you have a problem with you
know I probably because I'm in this
situation right now where I'm still my
hormones are out of whack probably I'm
more so the opposite you know where it's
like everything is just a super like a
wave of emotions and that's a very new
thing for me like I'm not like that
but it's something I'm dealing with and
probably this is it irritating for my
husband and I'm bawling I'm completely
crying I troubled not showing my
emotions right now which is a new and
interesting experience but it's it's
probably good and it's been good wrapped
up with that ego death and learning to
be a bit more human than just an online
figure what tell me more about that I
mean I'm interested well I had the same
I had the same experience when I was
full of hormones which was I was just
weepy over things that I'd like hated
being weepy over like ah why are you
going out so late it doesn't matter and
I know like before I was pregnant never
would have yeah never would have saw or
cared about it but it's yes it's all
running yeah
yeah they are I know people
underestimate that before I had a baby I
read something called these are really
good books
um the male brain and the female brain
and it explained like when twin women
get pregnant they get hormones and this
is kind of what happens but I didn't
realize how intense it is it's like I
had a 180 personality switch although it
was interesting it was cool and I'm
looking forward to it are you planning
on having more kids yeah I do want I do
want to have more for sure gonna take a
little bit of a break so I can enjoy
this I'm stabilizing you I'm still
there's so much to figure out around
pregnancy like even just getting my I
say body like my body is back to normal
but my my hormones and just daily life
cycle back to normal getting baby on a
sleep schedule like balancing alvey's I
think it's like a million different
spinning plates that you're working with
and that's also something that I like
for people that are like oh I want to
have babies I want to get married what's
the best tip that you can give well I I
would really caution against any kind of
listicle tips for this like going to a
website the top ten ways to find a
husband the top ten things to have a
baby like it is a complex and emotional
and deep journey that I mean if you're
gonna get into it yes to read the
research read the books but there's no
one trick that I can tell you that's
gonna help it's it's a lie it's life is
complex yeah yeah and having a baby
isn't like people underestimate what one
of the problems I've had with you know
society I've had many problems with
society as of you but like one of the
big ones was under estimating how
difficult it is to have a baby like as a
mom you're kind of put on a lower lower
on the totem pole
in society it's like oh you're a
stay-at-home mom say that you're a
stay-at-home mom you could be you know
CEOs up here a stay-at-home mom is down
here and being a mom is so intense that
experience is so much work like
emotional work physical work time sleep
deprivation it's so much
more work than anything else I've done
Oh completely and I think that the yeah
not giving enough credit to the role of
motherhood and how important it is in
society and how difficult it is causes
causes people to not sympathize with the
position that mothers are in and not
like like we can you'll see people women
who are mothers are even sometimes like
oh you're lazy you're at home all day
what you just watch Netflix what he just
likes it's like yeah no all of it
compounds maybe she's sitting and
watching Netflix for an hour because she
literally can't walk because she was up
all night
barely getting at wink asleep and she
just needs to sit down and literally
can't do anything with her mind her
brain is just so garbled with craziness
and baby crying like there it's a lot
it's totally a lot and it's not that
experience I think needs to be more
commonly talked about certainly in
recent television they have shows like
working moms and all of that that kind
of make a comedy of how crazy it is but
but I do think that needs to be
portrayed more and portrayed more to men
as well to prepare men for the
experience of being fathers and
supporting a woman going through that
it's it's a lot and it's a big change in
it you know when it's portrayed in
movies does this just yeah she picks up
the baby and it's all good and you know
it's just breast feeding and sitting
around like no no it's so much more than
that
yeah um what do you what advice I'm
gonna ask for more advice anyway but um
what advice would you give to women who
have a significant other and say that
they're already like late 20s and the
man is not interested in kids and the
woman is starting to get anxious about
that like what what do you say to like
those people because there are a lot of
them
oh man well like I'm not gonna suggest
you go and poke holes in the condom or
something you know if if you're dating
that and and kids is something you
really really want obviously that's
gonna have to be kind of a boundary or
an ultimatum in your relationship and
it's it's easy enough for me to sit here
online and tell you break up with them
and go find a guy that wants to have
kids but I know like that there would be
emotions attached to there they would be
like they're not going to do that vested
in this relationship that's that's a
tough one though because you don't you
can't force someone into something that
they don't want to do so the the best
thing that you can do is express your
want for this express what you what
you're feeling and also you know once
again another trophy that you see a lot
online is women women have this
biological clock at 30 and yes
completely I'm not gonna deny it I
remember going into the doctor's office
and they bring out this form and they're
like okay because you're in this age
bracket you are not going to have all of
these risks here that start 30 35 and I
remember sitting there and looking at
the form that they gave me in the
doctor's office and thinking it isn't
this offensive to say like you're not
allowed to say this online but a doctor
can tell it to me that's that's bizarre
so yeah I'm not gonna deny the the
biological fact that it's more difficult
for women as they get older to have kids
on a million different levels that's
true for Ben too though so all these
guys that are out here screaming about
well women you better have kids right
now cuz you're about to hit the wall the
clocks gonna know you have one two men's
sperm count starts to drop after 30
significantly their ability to conceive
conceive stop starts dropping chances of
schizophrenia autism all these things
and children start to go up as men age
past 30 35 and but more importantly than
all of that for both women and men just
the energy levels involved in raising a
kid and being able to play soccer with
them being able to enjoy a lot of these
things with your children that gets more
difficult as you get older dudes so you
guys need to be considering this as well
like you do have a biological clock -
that is ticking now I want to clarify
with if you are older and you want kids
I would never shame someone like that I
am sure it means it's such an amazing
thing all the best to you science and
technology we have today to help with
that is incredible but you know if these
are conversations that girls can have
with their husband you know if we want
to have a kid for both of us for the
sake of our youth - that you can play
soccer with them so that we can be young
enough to enjoy most of their lives with
them that's these are things you can
bring up to your partner because once
again I think that is a complete
nonsensical trope that it's only women
that have this biological clock that's
ticking men do - men do - and they just
they like to I don't know it's there's
always this weird gender roles gender
war going on online where it's what
about this for men but what about this
for women but what about this and that
don't like their problems and issues but
with both genders that can be
interesting yeah I completely agree I
mean I'm still in Belgrade and it's been
very strange like walking around other
than the fact there are actually people
outside which is different from when I
was in North America and everyone was
under quarantine but one of the weird
things is you'll have a group of you
know three couples and they're all 25
and there'll be toddlers running around
them and they'll be sitting there
together having coffee hanging out and
all their kids will be running around
them and I'm like sitting at the table
next to them just like staring because I
don't see at least in Toronto
no and when I had like 10 tell me what
your experience has been but when I had
scarlet and I was 25 all the women in my
neighborhood were 35 and I was like
somewhat shunned because the age gap was
too much and it was like who is this
person and I was just like I can
make friends cuz there's a decade age
gap thanks Society so what's your
experience been mine bar I went to a
family picnic and one of my nephew's who
is like he'd be an elementary school or
something I was pregnant and he looked
at me and he was like how old are you I
was like I'm 24 and he was like oh
you're a little young to be a mom aren't
you I remember sitting there and like he
like said it in a like very judgy tone
almost like it was like a teen pregnancy
24 to be a mom but that is like that is
the ideology within Western society
these days in childhood and like
adolescence is just it's being pushed
back further and further and further and
further you know you don't move out
until you're in your late 20s because
you got to go through the university you
don't have kids until you're in your 30s
late 30s and this is a this is a a
problem this is a problem that is caused
by our current economic situation you
know people can't buy houses they can't
afford to move out they can't afford to
have children this is a problem it's
made difficult on so many levels social
levels and it's it's a really sad thing
because there are probably a lot of
people that would love to have kids that
they just don't see it as financially
culturally socially feasible for them to
do any of this no it's pretty sad it's
sad to to look at the comparison because
people here and not everyone here but
people here are generally like looking
forward to having kids mid-20s early 20s
and with all their friends and so then
all their friends can have kids and then
you get like multiple people around you
helping out so it's like mmm it's less
work right if if all of you and your
friends have kids at the same time then
you can have like babysitting parties
and things it's not so isolating and
North America's just
it just isn't into that right now and
it's so sad it takes a village it
definitely takes a village and you know
I think people underestimate no not to
say that you should be having kids just
because you don't want to be lonely I
think that is a terrible idea
don't have kids that's the only reason
but there isn't interesting I've heard
this explained before but when you grow
older everything that you used to know
the show is you used to watch the shop
see used to go to the streets you used
to like they just start to decay and
disappear and get canceled off air even
friends you have older family members
they start to die and your life just
becomes animated by death decay like
aging and and
aging can be a beautiful process but
there's no longer anything new coming
about and if you have children that is
not the case you know you have new first
birthdays graduations weddings more
babies like creation and life exists
every step of the way as you age and you
have that as a part of your life whereas
if you don't have children or and it
doesn't have to even be children like it
can be maybe you're a teacher maybe
you're someone who engages at youth
group just with young people there's so
much life there's so much creativity and
art and just hopefulness it's like
bright-eyed and bushy-tailed attitude
and children that you just don't find in
adults so they're so cynical and we are
so cynical and we've aged at this point
we're bitter to the world and there
really is something I know it's very
stereotypical in cheesy but I genuinely
believe there is something that we can
learn from from young people who in in
their youthful ignorance still have this
capability to have such deep sense of um
just like they they genuinely trust in
you they genuinely love you they have
such pure emotions and excitement you
know when you go to a theme park with
them even when I show my son things for
the first time like water he is just so
amazed and excited and as he gets
excited splashing the water out like I
cannot believe how beautiful and freakin
amazing this thing is I sit there and I
remember water is an amazing beautiful
thing like why did I why did the world
look so dull to me before I had a son
who reminded me of all the beauty that
exists in it and there truly is and I'm
not saying I'm other people that can't
have kids I know there are people who
don't want kids or it's just not in the
cards for them but just having young
people involved in your life even if
it's volunteering with a with young
people if they bring a lot of they they
remind you about the beauty in the world
that you may have forgotten in your age
and cynicism yeah I completely agree and
Millennials probably understand puppies
better than children but puppies like it
like puppies kind of give you a taste of
that like they're overjoyed to see you
all the time right there it's like pure
butt and kids are like that except
completely different that's like a taste
right and kids are or they give you that
so much more and people underestimate
that they just think about diapers and
oh I'm not gonna be able to do whatever
I want to do play video games whenever I
want do cocaine or whatever it is you do
think I know everyone brings up diapers
and they're like I love my kids so much
he takes a poop and I'm like good job
bud you took a big - like I'm like let's
change your diaper like I'm excited to
change his diaper because I want him to
be happy and not have a poopy diaper
like I don't I'm not like oh I have to
change a diaper now like that isn't the
attitude I get around it at all and
unless you have kids you don't really I
don't I don't know it's hard to
understand the excitement of cleaning up
poop you don't just wait til like wait
till year to just wait till here - it
gets less exciting I swear it gets
blessings like for the first while you
like it's like taking care of a puppy
like you're you're enthusiastic about
making sure this thing this child has is
wonderful and healthy you know maybe
maybe that enthusiasm will just
I hope it doesn't okay well where can
people find you online Lauren yeah you
know not like I said I'm not really
posting much on Twitter I'm saving my
energy for the things that matter like
my large documentary projects and my
family but you can subscribe to me on
subscribe star where people are
supporting my documentary and I do post
video rants and do live streams there
and Instagram that's all I'm really
posting on at the moment
Instagram seems to have a surprisingly
healthy community compared to other
sites I'm not there every single social
media right it's it's because people I
guess for some reason I guess because
they see pictures of you they're the
people who really support you and on
Twitter you'll get a whole bunch of
people who hate you that also follow you
but on Instagram it doesn't seem to be
like that
Twitter needs therapy like everyone on
Twitter just think collectively it needs
to go to therapy I got a van we're all
going to the therapist oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah Twitter's a bit of a disaster
okay well thank you very much for coming
on and thank you for doing this since
you've been offline for so long it was
fun I think people will enjoy hearing
what it's like to be a mom especially
from people in their twenties not people
in there like 40s
not that there's okay and just just
before I get just before I end this I
like I feel like I said a bunch of
negative things to older people who have
kids I don't mean that at all I just
think having kids is great so like if
you want to start early I know a lot of
people who tried in their late 30s and
then couldn't and that's a tragedy right
so I just think if you can avoid that
it's good if you can manage to have kids
later or if you continue to have kids
later that's totally fine so and a good
parent who's in their late 30s is a
thousand times better than a bad parent
who's super young you know yeah like 11
games and yeah we're both kind of
entering that discrimination gap were
now us as young moms and old bombs were
both like this
yeah so much okay well thank you and I'm
sure we'll talk soon yeah this is a
pleasure
you